Сучасні гойдалки, креативні місця відпочинку, цікаві тематизовані локації, спортивні майданчики.
Родзинка Харкова - Центральний парк імені Горького, на який команда померлого мера Геннадія Кернеса не перший рік витрачає мільйони гривень
і вважає символом успішного Харкова, може стати причиною банкрутства міста.
Виплати кредиту, взятого у "Промінвестбанку" на реконструкцію парку і всі ці атракціони, тепер вимагають в суді.
Вимагаємо більше 6 млн євро і 42 млн гривень.
Депутати міськради Харкова в 2011-му проголосували за отримання кредиту для парку -
12,5 мільйонів євро і еквівалент 7,5 мільйонам євро в гривні за тогочасним курсом.
Під заставу віддали стратегічні об’єкти міста: майно метрополітену, зоопарк, кіноконцертний зал "Україна", кілька дитячих садків
та навіть будівлю мерії та міського Бюро технічної інвентаризації. Кредит мав бути повернутий ще 4 роки тому, в 2015-му.
Більшу частину від того, що мають виплатити, ще не виплатили, це 272 млн гривень загалом, якщо конвертувати, а виплатили лише 241 мільйон гривень.
Гасяться фактично лише відсотки кредиту. Сам кредит не погашений залишається.
Активісти Харківського Антикорупційного центру стверджують, що зібрали факти,
які нібито свідчать про те, що міська влада і парк не були зацікавлені в поверненні тіла кредиту.
При цьому сума виплат з 2011 року зросла майже втричі - через зростання курсу євро.
Можна було вже давно забути про цей кредит, віддати в 2015-му, як і обіцяв міський голова, коли відкривав парк після реконструкції.
Він обіцяв, що парк віддасть самостійно кредит за кошти, які заробить. І парк буде прибутковим.
При тому, що десятки атракціонів  працюють, десятки МАФів торгівельних працюють, парк, якщо і показує колись якийсь прибуток,
то він мінімальний, а іноді примудряється показати збитки.
З бюджету міста щорічно витрачається на підтримку фінансову парку і на виплату кредиту ще там 150-200 млн гривень.
Харківська міська рада з 2015-го року тричі продовжувала термін погашення кредитного боргу.
Останній термін погашення кредиту сплив у червні 2020-го.
Тоді в Харкові саме активно готувалися до місцевих виборів.
У вересні  мерія офіційно заявила про те, що Геннадій Кернес захворів на коронавірус і лікуватиметься в Німеччині.
У той же час і "Промінвестбанк" звернувся з позовом проти парку до Харківського обласного господарчого суду з вимогою про повернення коштів.
Запити Deutsche Welle про те, чи збирається банк, приміром, вимагати арешту заставного майна - метрополітену чи-то будівлі мерії -
пресслужба банку залишила без відповіді.
На питання, чи отримував банк якісь пропозиції від міськради чи парку про вирішення кредитного питання, його представник в суді теж багато не каже.
Мені про це не відомо. Можливо, керівництву, але мені про це не відомо.
У більшості фракцій міськради, з якими спілкувалася DW, не зовсім розуміють, чому виплата валютного кредиту так сильно затягувалася.
Адже ці кошти для бюджету Харкова не є непідйомними.
Багато хто з депутатів не розуміють, навіщо було ризикувати, віддаючи під заставу майно того ж метрополітену чи кіноконцертний зал.
Новообрані депутати вимагають від команди померлого Кернеса, яка фактично керує і мерією, і міськрадою,
захистити заставне майно і якомога швидше  повернути гроші.
Будівля, де ми зараз перебуваємо, теж під заставою. Тому в мене питання дуже просте: чи закладені в бюджет на 2021 рік кошти на повернення цього кредиту?
Якщо ні, то як місто збирається це робити? Я не розумію, чому банк досі…
Ми зараз перебуваємо в судовому процесі. І вам відомо, як довго ця процедура може тягнутися. Ми розуміємо, що ми робимо. Нічого страшного не відбудеться.
Ніхто наше комунальне майно у власність  не віддасть. Парк як функціонував, так і буде працювати. Тому заспокойтеся, все нормально.
Ще питання є? Немає!
Такий наполегливий оптимізм секретаря міськради, в минулому "правої руки" померлого Кернеса Ігоря Терехова, харківські антикорупціонери не поділяють.
Кілька років поспіль вони надсилають правоохоронцям численні звернення і щодо сумнівного кредиту, і щодо діяльності самого парку,
який попри шалений наплив відвідувачів, попри те, що тут скрізь є торгівельні майданчики, вся спортивна інфраструктура здається в оренду,
і ціни на атракціони теж немалі, чомусь не є прибутковим.
Крім того, активісти постійно оприлюднюють дані своїх розслідувань про те, що парк нібито проводить різні закупівлі за цінами, вищими за ринкові.
Реконструкція туалету в парку за 200 000 доларів, коли більше 5 млн грв витратили на туалет з  акваріумом, коли в них був непогашений кредит.
Вбачаємо ознаки корупції, вбачали і правоохоронні органи те, що не все чисто.
І було кримінальне провадження по парку Горького, і були обшуки у директора парку в  2014-2015 роках. Але це нічим не завершилося.
В принципі, ми вбачаємо, що дохід офіційний значно менший, ніж номінальний.
Антикорупціонери вважають реакцію правоохоронців формальною.
В цьому правоохоронна система Харкова з часів Віктора Януковича фактично не змінилася.
Не змінилося, за словами активістів, і те, що майже на кожному комунальному підприємстві Харкова вони виявляють фінансові оборудки,
марно сподіваючись на реакцію хоча б створеного після Революції гідності НАБУ.
НАБУ в цій історії могло звернути увагу на Кернеса? Могло!
Були кейси по команді Кернеса, які могли їх зацікавити? Могли.  Але  вони цього не зробили теж!
НАБУ у відповідь на запит Deutsche Welle підтвердило, що скарги на можливі неправомірні дії
службових та посадових осіб міськради Харкова від громадян до них надходили.
Однак через таємницю досудового розслідування НАБУ не може нічого повідомити щодо слідчих дій та будь-яких розслідуваннь.
Депутати міськради Харкова, з якими спілкувалася DW, не виключають,
що після смерті Геннадія Кернеса реакція правоохоронців може кардинально змінитися.
Мовляв, можливі нові резонансі кримінальні впровадження. Приміром, щодо того, як та кому останніми роками в  Харкові міськрада виділяла землі.
І чи є у Харкова ще якісь борги, наприклад, через придбання у великих обсягах комунальної техніки на умовах, які викликали критику активістів.
Київський політолог Володимир Фесенко вважає, що Харкову буде нелегко розібратися з борговим спадком померлого мера Кернеса.
Взагалі це парадоксальна ситуація. Є фасад успішного Харкова, і так партія його називалася.
І є імідж успішного міста і успішного мера, але за цим успішним фасадом є величезні борги. Це великий  ризик для міста.
Місто може бути потенційним банкрутом!  І це теж спадок Кернеса.
Хто б не керував містом, їм доведеться платити по боргах Кернеса і в прямому, і переносному сенсі .
Харківські активісти впевнені, що до продажу метрополітену чи будівлі мерії справа не дійде.
Проте розраховуватися за кредитом врешті-решт будуть звичайні харків’яни.
Адже за ці гроші натомість могли б відремонтувати фасади будівель в центрі міста, які вже падають на голови,
або ж оновити системи опалення і постачання гарячої води, які постійно виходять з ладу.